he had a tough challenge today Jeremy
because I think after being a leader for
only two weeks he did need to talk to
the conference hall and to our members
but he also needed to give the British
public a sense of who he is and what
drives him and you could never give a
full picture in a speech like that I
mean let's be honest about it but I
think he gave a good account of himself
and I think people saw a values-driven
politician he talked about is 30 years
of challenging human rights abuses I
think they saw a very principled man
with a clear idea about where he wants
to take the Labour Party and over the
weeks and months i'm sure he'll develop
those themes he talked about in his
speech today one of the things that he
didn't mention along with the the last
general election which I'm sure you're
wanting to recede into history as far as
possible was the whole question of the
deficit and any idea how you under his
leadership in your deputy leadership you
might deal with him on those two issues
I think the first thing I mean people
were really wanted to know about him and
what he wanted to do in the future we
are having a review of what went right
and wrong in the general election and
where we report it back on all of that
so I don't think that was a particular
issue and then on the deficit of course
the the speech on that was yesterday we
John went down on our new shadow
chancellor they work as a team John
McDonald is very clear he said we are
not deficit deniers we want to get down
the deficit but we might try and get it
down in different ways and over the
again you know over the next period
where we debate our policy in the
build-up to 2020 you'll be seeing more
on that he talked about a different
style of politics and using the online
community more in in the sort of
politics and the strategies that you
plan isn't there a danger though it's
going to sound rather like the public
through the online community is going to
be deciding your policies and your
strategies rather than yourselves well
let you know this through the work that
sky does Jeremy and you you have to go
where the audience's where voters are
and the national conversation is taking
much taking part is taking place online
and if Labour's not there then we're not
going to be able to do
and help shape that so we're both very
committed to reforming our own party to
make sure that we're a digital-first
party but these are you know that kind
of change in digitally talked about
there was also some traditions in there
as well you know at this conference the
two of us have been to 37 events where
we've been addressing members on all
sorts of issues and I think he's that
kind of politician he wants to connect
with the British people and he wants to
go and talk to them and listen to what
they've got to say he's a pluralist in a
Democrat and you know it dare I say a
great antidote to the politics of spin
that is probably afflicted politics for
about a decade more than it should have
done isn't there a danger though that by
being such a listening leader by
listening to the online community as
well he may be so democratic he fails to
make the decisions that are needed in
the end how do you marry that up well
it's early days it you know we've got a
fixed-term parliaments come out of an
election defeat he's only been in office
for a couple of weeks so I just say give
him a little bit of time let's help
shape a national conversation on some
issues that he feels very strongly about
and ask me that question in a couple of
years time Jeremy when we've gone out
and talk to the country okay a kinder
gentler more caring type of politics i'm
sure a lot of people would have poor
that but how does it work when if ennis
in essence Westminster is an adversarial
system well I think it's about
respecting the views that people hold
not sort of not dismissing what they
stand for and it was really interested
to me that the first standing ovation he
got was when he condemned the sort of
online trolling with it that some of our
colleagues that sort of suffered during
the leadership battle I mean drop
trolling online I mean I know a lot of
your own colleagues on Sky so for that
as well
and it's it you know i think that put
him in touch with their british people
are people are very worried about that
kind of intimidating approach and he was
set in a very clear stall where the
expense Labour Party members to treat
each other with respect I see some of my
colleagues not on sky just on sky but
across the whole media the commentariat
as he called it got a bit of a kicking
today how necessary is that how does the
help what's the point of that why does
it go downward we don't decide those
elections I don't think he was blaming
you Jeremy so there's no need for you to
worry but in the spirit of a kinder and
more caring politics I marked you are
you are but I think I think he was he
was having a little sideswipe at the
commentary and I can understand that you
know there are a lot of people who have
professional political commentators who
I I don't think I've really gone out of
their way to try and understand the
changes he wants to make and you know if
you are a political commentator I think
it's incumbent on you to try and
understand what a what a political
parties trying to do and I guess what he
was really saying was why does have
Rupert Murdoch's like David a ranid
[ __ ] from the time to get someone that
talks to him talks to Jeremy direct but
you know maybe that's my side swipe on
skype there we are you talking to jeremy
direct right now but a one last thought
though hear about the the wish list that
was laid out today was a pretty big wish
this there's a lot of things he says
that you and he and the rest of your
shadow cabinet want to do no suggestion
on how you going to pay for it and
that's been one of the downfalls the
Labour Party in the last few years
people are skeptical about your doing
your son's right you're getting the
economy right I understand that and that
but if we are we are at fundamental
stage you know we're just in the the
early stages of a new Parliament and I
don't think it's unreasonable for us to
sort of set out the direction of travel
without put in a price tag on everything
but what I thought was very interesting
yesterday from John McDonald speech I
mean he wants a fundamental review of
the way government
operates within the economy those
reviews of the Treasury in the Bank of
England were very very significant and
you know to bring in World economists
like Joseph Stiglitz who says you know
in a world where interest rates of
record lows you know maybe that's the
time you invest in capital
infrastructure that creates the jobs of
the future it's not unreasonable to set
the sort tone of the debate without
being specific in the early part of a
parliament I think well I very
interested it was our first experiment
in kinder gentler carrying political
interviews I think think we did all
right we'll see how well see what people
make of it Tom Watson thank you lady
with Thai boot I look forward to more
Jeremy thanks